("Piano Sonata No. 14 in
C-Sharp Minor, Op. 27")
- Ugh!
Ready?
Start.
(techno music)
- Why not?
(laughing)
Got 'em.
- K-Dramas became really popular
before K-Pop rose to its prominence
as we know of it today.
- [Cristina] Well, I'm Cristina.
- And I'm Daniela
- And we're K-drama experts.
- I have a question.
Are you two Korean?
- [Cristina] No.
- [Daniela] No.
- Okay,
- Ooh.
- just want to make sure.
- It's very interesting
to see how it became
a global phenomenon.
- [Voiceover] Korean culture is bringing
a lot of different people together
regardless of ethnicity.
- Just take a look outside of KCON.
- Yeah, all these people here.
(laughing)
- All these beautiful people.
- Fans play a huge role
and Korean drama fans tend
to be extremely knowledgable.
- What is a K-Drama?
- K-Drama is a Korean Drama.
- Is it all in the Korean language?
- [Cristina] Yes.
- [Daniela] Yes.
- We have dramas.
Are they different?
- Korean dramas in Korea used to be
entertainment form
designed for housewives.
However, that notion is
completely challenged nowadays.
- Today we are doing a few scenes from
very popular K-Dramas.
- [Voiceover] "My Love From Another Star,"
- [Voiceover] " The Heirs,"
- [Voiceover] and "My
Unfortunate Boyfriend."
- To show that we can act.
Ding!
- Ohhh!
- I noticed that there
are certain tropes that
you can't really escape when
you're watching a K-Drama.
- K-Drama cliches that
people tend to identify...
- Dramatic looks
(inhaling)
- [Dr. Suk-Young] Car accidents
that result in amnesia.
(gasp)
Forgotten past that leads
to dangerous incest.
- But father!
- Love story between poor
girl with a heart of gold
and rich handsome guy.
(Speaking Korean)
- They are recycled over and over
and over again for people tend to
cling to those stories to escape and
just forget about it all.
- Do people fall in love and then
their love complicates the plot?
(laughing)
That's a good show.
- [Voiceover] How do
they fight in K-Dramas?
- There's a lot of,
either passive aggressive
like (grunts) like looks.
Or like collar grabbing.
(grunts)
(laughing)
- [Daniela] Or kicking
- [Cristina] Kicking.
- [Daniela] the chest
- [Voiceover] Kicking him in the chest?
- Yes. (laughing)
- Who kicks people the chest?
(Speaking Korean)
(kicking and painful grunt)
- Hey, are you out of your mind?
- You, shut up.
- I can't see. I'm blinded.
(laughing)
- What do they do in K-Dramas that
that's funny?
- Stripping and falling
accidentally on each other...
- Ooo ooo ooo whoa. Whoooa ho
- K-Drama Comedies are like slapstick.
- [Daniela] Yep.
- [Cristina] Yeah.
- Excuse me?
Excuse me, can you move?
I said move, ahh.
K-Drama Comedies?
- Yeah.
- Why don't they
just call them K-Comedies?
- Where are we going?
- Uh oh.
- Ooo!
- My hair is caught in your zipper.
I spilled all the glue on my hand.
(slap) Oooh!
- Oooh!
- What makes a K-Drama romance scene?
- "My Love From Another Star."
So I'm Min-joon
and you're Song-yi.
- Yeah.
- There's also that tension.
- I was diagnosed with
depending too much on you.
I was diagnosed with that.
(laughing)
- Koreans are more soft piano,
snow falling.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- Ohhhh.
- Yeah.
- Look off and go...
(sighs) Are you drunk already?
- Are you drunk already?
- No.
Not at all.
- Women don't sit like that.
(laughing)
- Right.
Like this?
How do they sit in Korea?
- How do they sit in Korea?
It's still, they're still women.
(laughing)
- Still women.
- Give me fifteen seconds.
(laughing)
- Wait.
Let's begin.
- [Cristina] There's way too
- [Daniela] What's hap--
- [Cristina] much chemistry
- [Daniela] What's happening?
- [Cristina] happening here.
(laughing)
- Wait a minute. (laughs)
- Korean Dramas,
it like takes maybe up to even
episode six to even like kiss the person.
- When are they gonna kiss?
- Keith's face is so malleable.
You can just like do
anything you want to it.
(laughing)
It's really,
look how kissable that is.
- [Voiceover] Oh yeah.
- (muffled) I'm,
I'm blessed.
- [Voiceover] Alright so umm,
no we're going to actually shoot it
(dramatic music)
as if we're in the drama.
("Piano Sonata No. 14 in
C-Sharp Minor, Op. 27")
- Why not?
- You can't drink with a piece of pottery?
You couldn't drink with a dog?
I guess you couldn't
even drink with a tree.
(huffs)
- Are you drunk already?
- No, not at all.
But I'm full of chemistry.
All men go crazy for me.
- [Keith] I start a fire in their hearts.
Do women have chemistry when they see me?
No.
- If you're not drunk...
(huffs)
you should see a shrink.
- (laughs) I already did.
- [Keith] I was diagnosed with
depending too much on you.
But how can you refer to me as pottery,
a dog or a tree?
This has never happened in my life.
- Give me fifteen seconds.
- Why fifteen seconds?
- They call me the "Fairy
of Fifteen Seconds."
I capture people's
attention in fifteen seconds
in the commercials.
- Give me fifteen seconds.
(piano music)
Ugh!
- Ready?
Start.
(music swells)
(gentle slap)
(moaning)
(music swells)
(kissing)
(snickering)
(peck)
(kissing and laughing)
(coughing)
- I'm afraid...
of what we're going to be.
(cough)
(laughing)
- It's the food of my home planet.
- [Voiceover] Go back to your
(laughing)
alien planet
and don't you come back here again.
(techno drums)
- [Voiceover] I'm a jewel of jealousy.
(laughing)
Just grab my face.
- Don't hold me like
(laughing)
you're stalling Shakespeare.
- You're Hamlet and I'm just dead.
(laughing and chatter)
(metal creaking)
Ohhh!